oh
boom alvin
that's a beautiful burger
[Laughter]
whoa
[Music]
what's the best burger it's a question
i've been asked a million times but i
think we're approaching it the wrong way
what we should be asking is what is the
best burger based on your budget do you
have 5
15 or 20 bucks in your pocket so i
invited my old buddy elijah wood to go
on an la burger tasting quest with me
and see what the best of each price
point has to offer
what up burger show alvin kailan here
with my boy
elijah wood hey man so people don't know
this but we we've known each other for a
really long time a long time everything
i've opened you've showed up to yeah now
you get to be on the show i'm so excited
dude what's your favorite burger
what makes it great it really is a
spectrum right i think my favorite my
preference has has come to be
the simplest the better
so the idea of stacking your burger with
tons of ingredients was something that i
did when i was younger and i i wanted i
want like meat bun cheese maybe an aioli
of some kind and that's it maybe some
pickles that's honestly because it's
gotta be and the ratio has to be right
from burger to bun i don't even have to
be here guys
but that's so no it's true it's so
important
what are you eating you're eating the
the meat and that has to be the star
agreed and and
all of the other sort of accoutrements
ultimately take away from yeah paying
attention to simplicity
skill almost on like how it's built the
construction yeah is so important we're
gonna take some delicious burgers none
of these are gonna suck because we've
vetted them vetted them out right and
then we're going to talk about the
glorious sense of their price awesome
cool yes very cool let's do it let's go
[Music]
my name is elvia my name is alex garcia
and we're here in ibaka's el sereno uh
it's called ebook cooks because you know
the devil is in the details the max
satan is uh basically a simple cheese
burger taco
uh that we started doing it
in honor of uh the creator in mexico 30
years ago
tacos antonio but we did our own version
giving the evil twist i think people's
reactions were
what the [ __ ]
but then there's people that are like
blown away like oh my god like what is
this what we do with the beef for the
cheeseburger is we add some onions
garlic oregano bambimbo so we get our
ball of meat and then we smash it in our
tortilla press we slap it on the flat
top flip it add some american cheese and
while that's going we'll drop a little
bit of mozzarella cheese onto the flat
top we press our tortilla cook it off
and then put that on top of the cheese
and then we'll top it with our
caramelized onions mixed with our salsa
add our guacamole bacon
and that's it
we love to break roof because
that's what rules are made for
[Music]
wait is this a burger taco burger number
one what the hell is happening it's
called the mix satan they do tacos and
they're a pop-up for now this is their
version of a burger oh this is so you
know
is it a burger is it a taco it's a
burger taco let's give it a try yes
dude
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
whoa
oh my god that's such a beautiful clash
of elements i can honestly say i've
never had anything like this before
stop like this why hasn't this existed
until now it shakes me to my core
yeah because this is a five dollar
piece of art you're getting savory
you're getting there's acid in there
you're getting smoking from the bacon
those onions too caramelized onions it
is doing something to my brain
yeah i mean because like like the a
proper definition of a burger is you
know chopped beef in between buns
i mean arguably a tortilla is a pond
shark sure
like you throw another tortilla on top
of this it's pretty much a sandwich yep
this is a burger all in all
that anxious
gooey gooey
cheeseburger
is is the soul of this particular taco
this is a destination
item like i would drive out of my way to
get this agreed for five bucks that's
insane five dollars
to relate it to you know like your world
it's like this is like going to
you know sundance
and then
you're like this unassuming indie movie
just comes out of nowhere and just
[ __ ]
slays slays the entire festival that's
what this is i love that it's a great
analogy all right on to the next burger
number two
let's go
[Music]
i'm christina corrageous known as tina
from pasadena my father and uncle
started lucky boy it started 1961.
most of our employees are here with us
40 years we make a lot of breakfast
burritos and a lot of hamburgers my
family they are greek immigrants greek
men women children we all cook together
so cooking is just part of our culture
the patty melt is really delicious
because it's so buttery so you take your
patty put on the char broiler in the
meantime you've got to get your onions
on the flat top
then you take your bread and get that on
the flat top really grease it up with
lots of butter take your burger flip it
pack on those
onions
press it
out to go
smelt
[Music]
okay
is that a hamburger sandwich on rye
this is the patty melt from pasadena's
treasure lucky boy this is the most
underrated sandwich slash burger in the
entire city wow this is actually a new
thing in my in my in my life because
i've been going to lucky boys
for their breakfast burrito everyone
knows them for their breakfast yeah okay
they're always number one on the list
for breakfast burrito yep and then my
line cook
was moving to new york and i'm like
where could we go for a burger you know
what what do you crave you're leaving to
new york what are you gonna miss the
most like the patty mel at lucky boy i'm
like you're crazy they only do breakfast
burritos
so we we went and i tried it and the
moment i i took one bite i was like
okay now i get it yeah let's give it a
go
[Music]
the crispiness those onions are insane
it's got a lot of onions the amount of
butter
used to toast this
is essential yeah and there's a lot it's
almost like a fried sandwich i love rye
bread i love it i love the caraway seeds
i love that flavor profile of it
texture's awesome so that you can get
that experience and still have the
innards of a burger is magic to me in
the bar of all patty melts this is
like you have to get better than this if
not don't even bother i agree go to
lucky boy let's get to the third burger
we're ready we're hungry
oh
boom alvin
that's a beautiful burger can we just
for a second yeah look at the [ __ ]
thing i mean i'm throwing this that is
picture perfect i'm throwing my hat
in the ring this is something that i'm
proud of because we are a full-scale
like steak boutique butcher shop that's
right and so this is the burger that we
use to showcase and i think that
anywhere in this country this burger
goes above and beyond the particular
price point and this is 15 at my
restaurant so you think this is fighting
way above its weight oh for sure yeah i
mean this can go up against the grates
in los angeles that are 30 and more
this bun is custom just made for me okay
it's a milk bun it has a dry aged
brisket chuck and it has wagyu and every
trim that we have in our case
goes in this burger so this is comprised
of steak
how are you selling it at this price
point we're going with regular dill
pickles
aioli caramelized onions nothing crazy
yeah okay we use provolone cheese
because we want it to be mild we're
literally
letting the beef shine
there's a there's a degree of flex
happening here let's try it let's try it
[Music]
oh god
dude this is a
this is a fine dining
restaurant burger this is definitely
again this is not something that you
would see for that this price point at
all that i definitely know this is a 25
or more depending on where you're
getting it the series
is this like a half pound
10 ounces wow it's basted in tallow
so we cook it like a steak if there was
one burger to rule them all
and because we're friends we could do
this okay and in my opinion yeah
this is it we're west coast boys and we
like thin patties yep
pound for pound apples to apples
for 15
you can't beat that i i i have to agree
with you um because i would also throw
like men at a tavern into the mix like
that burger that's 30 right shoot you
can't you can't be schmiegel will be all
over this [ __ ]
we call this the dh burger dh yeah so
only real ones of the burger show know
why this is named the dh could we call
it the deluxe hamburger if like a soccer
mom comes and
it looks deluxe right
but the reality and the inspiration of
this burger
is from seth rogen so he was a guest of
ours on the show yeah i think i've seen
that one and he said thick patties are
for [ __ ]
right
i don't know if i'd agree with that but
i it's not normally my preference yeah
yeah you heard it here first everyone
who comes to the shop and giggles when
you order it you're right
the [ __ ] burger for 15
unstoppable
bring it on
last final baller burger let's get it
let's do this
[Music]
hi i'm walter manske i'm the chef owner
of republique
at the heart and soul and the core of
republic is a french restaurant
but
it's also integrated
with the melting pot of cultures that
are in los angeles this magical
building where charlie chaplin put
together in 1928 everything you eat and
drink here is elevated because of the
surroundings that's around you the
burger is inspired
by the iconic burger of in and out so
we've taken that and just elevated it my
wife bakes the bread every day
when we butcher the beef we take all the
trim and the fat from those very
expensive ribeyes and grind it into the
hamburger meat the combination of that
creates a flavor that's just magical
i've tried so many different things i
tried
very
expensive high-end cheese i tried foie
gras
it just interferes with the
essence and the heart and soul of the
burger and takes away from it
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
yo these knives what what is happening
here
so this is the dry aged
burger from republic okay i mean if
you're looking at it it has all of the
ingredients
to be the classic american burger that's
pretty but this is from a fine dining
restaurant right it's it's an elevated
um
in-n-out burger basically yeah you
almost don't want to bite it right now
it's so gorgeous it's very aesthetically
pleasing it's it's perfect
cheers
oh my god
oh yeah i need one more
this is why it's on the bush
it's so good
on like a technical scale they do
bottoming it's not toppings and i love
that i love that too because
it falls out otherwise yes that's the
great control yep the onion confit you
get it right here and then it's like
it's like onion jam yeah it's so good it
is so good it's pretty [ __ ] stellar
we're not at republic right now but when
you you go into this like classically
french you feel like you're almost like
in notre dame
and ice is really smart yeah like if
you're gonna get this burger in that
setting
at 19
[ __ ] 19. at 19. 20 even yeah that's just
this is impressive that's impressive
they nailed it they did a lot of things
right which you know you could also go
the other way it's just the thing that
often happens is that there's i think
it's overthinking for sure i don't order
burgers usually at like a like a sit
down beautiful fine dining restaurant
nor do i unless there's a sort of light
being shown on that particular yeah and
this has been the one that i think
throughout the city everyone talks about
it's like the republic burger worth
every penny agreed worth everybody no
that's that's super stellar so of the
four
whoa what of the four what are you
loving
it's it's between two okay it's between
um the taco burger okay and amboy burger
i
and i'm not i'm not that taco burger
that that really looks really satan
thing that's a thing yeah
go
seek that out that is that is a thing
when they're popped up you better be
there it's the stuff of dreams it's the
it's when something in when somebody
invents something that you've never had
yeah and it works like that it's so
revelatory yeah i'm glad we got to do
this together man dude this was so much
fun thank you for this fun we got to do
it again yes for sure anytime burger
show baby elijah
let's go
[Music]
what's up y'all it's your boy alvin
kylon of the burger show make sure you
like
subscribe and hit that notification bell
if not for me
for the burger